well a powerful typhoon has struck the
philippines packing winds of up to 195
kilometers an hour over a hundred
thousand people were evacuated with one
charity warning that super typhoon rye
could hit coastal communities like a
freight train ride comes late in the
philippines typhoon season where
cyclones more commonly happen between
july and october experts say climate
change is making typhoons stronger and
more unpredictable
so let's bring in jc gotenka a
journalist from the philippines capital
manila hi there welcome to the show uh
we've just heard the typhoon has made
landfall can you tell us a bit more
about what the situation is like there
right um yes the land the the typhoon is
already within the philippine land mass
and we're seeing reports of failed power
lines block roads
some small landslides
from different parts that are affected
by the typhoon already power is out in
many areas and in one major city in the
south of the country called cagayan de
oro a major river there has burst its
banks and
parts of the city are majorly flooded
there are communities and villages that
are totally submerged
so major flooding we also know up to a
hundred thousand people have already
been evacuated do we know what is going
to happen to them now
um
as usual they've been evacuated to
mostly school houses in their localities
also government halls as well as sports
stadiums that are near their area uh the
concern of course will be access to food
clean water
safe spaces for them to stay with their
families and of course the kovit 19
pandemic adds a layer of problems
to the situation um imagine these are
hundreds or even thousands of families
uh staying in close quarters within uh
close proximity of one another and of
course it becomes an opportunity for the
virus to spread uh the philippines just
yesterday reported its first cases of
the omicron variant of the virus um
although it's not likely that it's
already spread within the community but
definitely this typhoon is raising
concerns of increased transmission we
have just seen some footage of quite
dramatic rescue efforts there what are
forecasters saying about the path that
this typhoon is going to be taking now
right um
forecasters are saying that the typhoon
has intensified um
as you have said
some categorizations already place it as
a super typhoon a 195 kilometer per hour
winds with gustiness of up to 270 000
kilometers 270 sorry kilometers per hour
one observer said that
these winds could hit
coastal communities especially like a
freight train so you can imagine the
force that these winds will be coming to
these communities it is expected to
bear down right across the country's
central and southern regions and it
might be here until late saturday jc
gotcha from manila please stay safe
thank you so much for that update on dw
news thank you
you